Now that we've
trained a model, we
need to evaluate
it on the test set.
So let's build an
object called pred
that has the predicted
probabilities
for each class from
our cart model.
So we'll use predict of
emailCART, our cart model,
passing it newdata=test,
to get test set predicted
probabilities.
So to recall the
structure of pred,
we can look at the first
10 rows with predpred[1:10,].
So this is the rows we want.
We want all the columns.
So we'll just leave a comma
and nothing else afterward.
So the left column here is
the predictive probability
of the document
being non-responsive.
And the right column is
the predictive probability
of the document
being responsive.
They sum to 1.
So in our case,
we want to extract
the predictive probability of
the document being responsive.
So we're looking for
the rightmost column.
So we'll create an
object called pred.prob.
And we'll select the right
most or second column.
All right.
So pred.prob now
contains our test set
predicted probabilities.
And we're interested
in the accuracy
of our model on the test set.
So for this computation,
we'll use a cutoff of 0.5.
And so we can just
table the true outcome,
which is test$responsive
against the predicted outcome,
which is pred.prob >= 0.5.
What we can see here
is that in 195 cases,
we predict false when the left
column and the true outcome
was zero, non-responsive.
So we were correct.
And in another 25, we correctly
identified a responsive
document.
In 20 cases, we identified
a document as responsive,
but it was actually
non-responsive.
And in 17, the
opposite happened.
We identified a document
as non-responsive,
but it actually was responsive.
So our accuracy is 195 +
25, our correct results,
divided by the total
number of elements
in the testing set,
195 + 25 + 17 + 20.
So we have an accuracy
in the test set of 85.6%.
And now we want to
compare ourselves
to the accuracy of
the baseline model.
As we've already established,
the baseline model
is always going to predict the
document is non-responsive.
So if we table test$responsive,
we see that it's going to be
correct in 215 of the cases.
So then the accuracy
is 215 divided
by the total number of
test set observations.
So that's 83.7% accuracy.
So we see just a
small improvement
in accuracy using the cart
model, which, as we know,
is a common case in
unbalanced data sets.
However, as in most document
retrieval applications,
there are uneven costs for
different types of errors here.
Typically, a human will
still have to manually review
all of the predicted
responsive documents
to make sure they are
actually responsive.
Therefore, if we have
a false positive,
in which a non-responsive
document is labeled
as responsive, the
mistake translates
to a bit of additional
work in the manual review
process but no further harm,
since the manual review process
will remove this
erroneous result.
But on the other hand, if
we have a false negative,
in which a responsive document
is labeled as non-responsive
by our model, we will
miss the document entirely
in our predictive
coding process.
Therefore, we're going to sign
a higher cost to false negatives
than to false positives, which
makes this a good time to look
at other cut-offs
on our ROC curve.